hello today you are joining me on a
field trip to Russia three centuries ago
Russian Tsar
it was a great decided to establish the
only target was solely on all scientists
in Russia it didn't stop Sousa and he
traveled through Europe trying to
convince leading human sciences to
relegate Russia he did not succeed since
Russia was considered and predictable
and even dangerous country except
however johann bernoulli is a leading
European mathematician passed the
invitation into history
Liyana
in 1735 Euler saw the famous seven
bridges of königsberg the city of
Canonsburg is the Kingdom of Prussia was
built on two sides of the river
track and consisted of two islands that
we are connected by seven bridges with
each other and there is Mae it's a
problem force to find the world to see
that the cross every bridge exactly was
in return world not only solves this
problem for a small city of can expect
seven bridges he develop a universal
idea of how to solve such problems for
imaginary cities with his means
this is Inasa privately
and our goal today is to find the corpse
with a city that would visit every page
exactly once there are many strategies
to explore let's go I'll meet you at the
next page wait a second
but what Simon Bridges of hanoks that
have to do is buy
may come as a surprise but is Oh Tyler
we probably wouldn't be in to assemble
there we can send about your chain is a
very long strand of Silverland
and four decades ago biologists figure
out how to change but they stayed on a
mythology that would be able to read the
Jenna from the first nucleotide to the
last night as if you would need to move
what they can't do so is to breathe
short snippets of genome for reads
something that may be very short like
200 or 300 movement the problem however
is biologists do not know from what
region of the genome
each snippet ordinary came from and as a
result they have to figure out how to
assemble them together doses such great
details over balconies and uses are to
figure out how serious for chasm is
essentially it is
again what it has to do these seven
bridges of connection today we will
learn millions of islands and millions
of pages in such a way that every bridge
corresponds to the DNA
enough to learn how to walk in this
magazine you will be able to assemble
checks I'll meet you at the next bridge
after the other
you